madeleine et sébastien valeur un
collègue bonsoir alors ben forcément
aujourd'hui c'était l'histoire la
journée à ses projections et qui
inquiète grandement justin trudeau et
son gouvernement on a vu le symbole
monsieur trudeau quittant télétravail
fait son point de presse devant rideau
carthage
on va écouter un extrait de ce point de
presse puis ensuite on jase ensemble
je peux ici parce que ça me tente de
l'être et je sais que ça vous tente pas
de me voir ici devant ma maison encore
une fois en train de dire il va falloir
qu'on fasse des sacrifices tout je sais
que les gens sont fatigués je sais que
les gens sont tannés
mon dieu que c'est plate de co2 19la
alors madeleine à vous la parole en
trois milieux sur le choix des mots les
lieux l'ensemble de l'oeuvre
qu'est ce que vous retenez mais c'est un
symbole un et justin trudeau a pas
beaucoup de levier pour persuader la
population de suivre les conseils de
santé publique parce que lui c'est pas
lui qui les dictent ces mesures là ce
sont les provinces et il n'a pas
l'intention de s'accaparer ses pouvoirs
lors il le dit à plusieurs reprises
qu'il voulait pas invoquer la loi sur
les mesures d'urgence qu'il ne voulait
pas avoir une approche parapluie partout
au pays avec les mêmes et eu les mêmes
consignes partout et il a même dit
aujourd'hui en point de presse
pour ceux qui trouvent que c'est injuste
par exemple des restaurants qui sont
fermés dans une région est ouvert dans
une autre il a dit oui c'est injuste
c'est comme ça va falloir passer au
travers
donc il fait confiance aux provinces de
dicter les consignes mais lui il veut
essayer d'encourager les canadiens de
les suivre ses consignes donc là la
santé publique ont mis la table avec des
données quand même assez inquiétante en
disant que si on maintient le niveau de
contact comme il est actuellement mon va
avoir vingt mille cas quotidiennement
d'ici la fin de l'année donc imaginer on
mute records quotidien actuel par quatre
c'est toute une hausse ça donc ce que
dit le gouvernement maintenant c'est que
chacun supplémentaires met une pression
supplémentaire sur le système de santé
donc il essaie de convaincre avec les
moyens qu'il peut sébastien mais y avait
il y avait quelque chose dans le ton
aujourd'hui de justin trudeau était
particulièrement sérieux graves
inquiétants un peu plus pays disait
c'est pas facile cette de covili a
ajouté un bon petit sac
on sentait une certaine familiarité dans
le choix des mots il vous est
engage une rhétorique proche du monde
oui avec un peu aussi c'était très bien
illustré dans l'extrait que vous avez
passé mais en même temps c'est quand tu
regardes à l'ouest sont en train de
flamber l'alberta le manitoba la
saskatchewan l'ontario il savait que
d'oxford allait annoncer plus tard dans
l'après midi des mesures pour la région
de toronto
la région de peel pub donc il voulait
peel avait cette projection de sa santé
publique vingt mille cas par jour alors
qu'on est à cinq mille actuellement donc
vous allez me dire il ya toujours un
petit côté dramatique avec avec justin
trudeau mais aujourd'hui c'était
particulièrement marqué souligné payer à
cause des événements qui l'entourent
actuellement et je termine en disant
qu'il y avait probablement une apparence
de double discours dans la façon dont
monsieur trudeau a abordé les choses par
rapport à ce que monsieur legault nous a
dit hier justin trudeau il dit c'est pas
le temps de faire le party restez chez
vous moi je m'aime je vais m'en cabanes
et chez moi puis j'irai pas voir des
amis ou quoi que ce soit
pierre françois legault nous dit bart va
pouvoir se rassembler pendant les fêtes
alors la nuance parce que nous on suit
c'est d'heure en heure la nuit on sait
que justin trudeau et y rester chez vous
pour les prochaines semaines parce qu'on
va essayer peut-être de pouvoir faire
des choses à noël mais dans les
prochaines semaines c'est important de
réduire la progression de la maladie et
de faire en sorte qu'on stabilise la
situation juste avant de poursuivre avec
madeleine du couteau justement justin
trudeau par rapport au québec et aux
choix du gouvernement nos goûts
le premier ministre le go est en train
de faire tout ce qu'il peut pour
reconnaître la réalité dans laquelle les
gens vivent pour encourager les gens de
faire tout ce qui est nécessaire pour
limiter leurs contacts
on est encore loin de noël il reste
encore beaucoup de semaines d'ici là
dans lesquelles nous allons pouvoir
prendre les mesures nécessaires pourra
partir la courbe
et ça certains madeleine se sont levés
ce matin en se disant il va et vos
critiques et le golan si on voyait le
contraste venir entre les deux messages
mais donc ça s'est pas produit j'imagine
quand même que ça faisait pas son
affaire de passer pour le grinch de noël
après que françois legault la veille et
dit que ce serait possible de se
rassembler en petits groupes pendant
quatre jours pendant le temps des fêtes
mais en même temps comme sébastien l'a
mentionné
on parle d'une mesure immédiate il
demande aux canadiens immédiatement de
restreindre le nombre de contacts qu'ils
ont pour espérons-le à aplatir la courbe
du si noël
donc je n'ai pas critiqué françois
legault et il aurait été très mal avisé
de le faire puis et au moins deux
raisons pour ça pour ça la première
c'est que je le disais tout à l'heure
c'est pas lui qui a le lourd poids de
dicter les consignes de santé publique
donc c'est pas lui qui a à prendre les
appels des restaurateurs des
propriétaires de jim qui sont mécontents
lorsqu'il ya des des mesures qui
restreignent finalement l'ouverture de
certains commerces
premièrement deuxièmement ces six-là
veut dire que ce que françois legault
fait ça commencerait à a finalement
peut-être semer des doutes sur la
pertinence des mesures qui sont
décrétées par une province alors que lui
au contraire demande aux canadiens aux
québécois suivez les conseils
si on commence à dire bombe et celle ci
je n'aime pas trop celle là je pense que
c'est pas une bonne idée ça discrédite
un petit peu les premiers ministres qui
essaient de faire de leur mieux en ce
moment
finalement il n'y a pas besoin d'une
autre chicane avec qui il travaille ça
c'est peut-être la dernière vague notée
l'état des lieux puisqu'il s'est passé
dans chacune des provinces au cours des
48 dernières heures dont hier françois
legault parce que sa situation est
relativement stable il a pu ouvrir sur
noël
si les hôpitaux débordés psylle nombre
de cas était à 2000 par jour il aurait
pas pu faire la non ce qu'il a fait hier
françois legault en contraste l'alberta
est en train de resserrer les règles
seul le nombre de cas est en train de
monter d'oxford aujourd'hui a annoncé
des mesures pour piler toronto les
premiers ministres de ces provinces où
les cars sont moins ce temps disons
qu'au québec sont pas en mesure de
parler de noël alors a plongé lundi ce
noël qui nous donne
un indice sur l'état des lieux dans
chacune des provinces
si françois legault incapable de parler
de noël c'est parce que c'est
relativement stable alors que les autres
premiers ministres sont en rattrapage
sur des mesures de confinement plus
sévère parce que ils n'ont pas réussi à
stabiliser la situation dans leur
province
ils sont pas encore capables de parler
de noël à un monet non ce serait
prématuré de le faire ils en parlent
dans bien des cas de province qui ont
été plus ou moins ont relativement
épargné lors de la première vague mais
pour la deuxième c'est une autre
histoire
on va passer maintenant au prochain
sujet hier étant donné bon l'émission
spéciale qu'on vous a présenté avec
cette annonce de monsieur legault en
mode panel on a moins le temps de
revenir sur la question du français
et là le dernier développement c'est
cette députée libérale qui est tout
initié cette semaine qui a finalement
quitte le comité parlementaire hockey
aux siens au sein duquel siégeaient on
les coupe haye ont été profondément
touché par les réactions depuis vendredi
dernier et comprenant la sensibilité
engendrés par mes propos j'aimerais
aujourd'hui vous informé monsieur le
président de ma volonté de quitter mes
fonctions au c'est au sein de ce comité
à la fin de cette rencontre
sa décision madeleine l'eau peut-être
était très incités à la prendre cette
décision là c'est du moins ce que j'en
comprends et à la prendre rapidement
parce que le gouvernement avait hâte de
mettre tout ce dossier là derrière lui
ça n'a pas été une bonne semaine
du côté de ce dossier du français parce
que le gouvernement les libéraux de
justin trudeau se servent ou ce servette
cette question là pour de deux façons
premièrement comme d'une arme d'attac là
ils l'ont fait par exemple lorsque le
gouvernement ford avait fait des
compressions dans les services en
français il avait essayé d'associer les
conservateurs fédéraux à cette idée là
ça c'était mode attaque il y avait le
mode larmes séduction ou si on essayait
de séduire les québécois francophones en
disant on veut moderniser la loi sur les
langues officielles
on veut protéger le français même au
québec donc ça c'était une grande
nouveauté qui avait été annoncé et lors
de sa vie un petit peut nuire à cet
effort leur nuire à la crédibilité des
libéraux surtout qu'ils n'ont pas encore
procédé à cette modernisation de la loi
sur les langues officielles dont ça met
beaucoup beaucoup de pression sur le
gouvernement d'agir rapidement mais en
fait ça jette un doute sur la véritable
nature ou le la véritable volonté justin
trudeau de changer les choses puis de
renforcer les langues officielles en
particulier le français à montréal
un député de montréal monsieur trudeau
de la région de montréal avec des gens
qui disent qu'il est pas vraiment
sincère dans cette volonté là alors
quand une députée sort comme ça durant
une des petites du québec en personne la
circonscription de saint-laurent
quelques scènes de stéphane dion quand
même 16 heures puis une autre qui est
responsable de du plc québec madame
pecresse demain dit que la loi 101 était
était une abomination enfin s'est passé
vraiment mais elle a utilisé un autre
qualificatif pour l'éducation en anglais
au québec
j'ai mis leur salle devant moi ça
renforce sa renforce la trame narrative
des adversaires de justin trudeau qui
disent regardez il est pas vraiment
sérieux regarder à l'intérieur de son de
son parti à des gens qui pensent que le
français pendant dé clermont
et que donc sa volonté de vouloir
renforcer le français n'est qu'un effet
de tout donc la démission le fait
qu'elle quitte labro poule ça va pas
remettre la marmite sur sur la la cache
découverte pardon sur la marmite
d'une part ça peut quand même aidé ça
peut quand même aidé parce que
l'opposition pas tous les partis mais
plusieurs partis qui demandait justement
qu'elle quitte qu'elle lui cède son
siège sur le comité des langues
officielles
une chose mais l'autre chose et je
reviens à ça la modernisation sur les
langues officielles juste être doux l'a
promis dans son discours du trône ben
ali voici le processus j'imagine mais
faut-il encore qu'il soit prêt oui alors
si ça prend du temps il ya beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'organismes à
consulter c'est ce travail là et déjà
commencé mais selon ce que j'en
comprends il n'est pas encore terminée
donc on veut pas non plus précipité les
choses arriver avec une modernisation
qui fait pas la faire et là c'est bon
finalement on contribue au problème
plutôt qu'on essaie de le régler mais
vous savez quoi ici à québec on est
prêts on est prêt à réformer la loi
censi mon mari ils votent sur toutes les
tribunes ce dimanche des barrettes pour
dire qu' il va le faire
sauf que pour l'instant c'est juste des
paroles parce qu'il n'est pas encore
passé à l'action
c'est une affaire de stratégie
semble-t-il on attend le bon moment pour
déposer projet ligue nationale les
conditions gagnantes
il est déjà possible caucus il est déjà
passé par conseil des ministres mais en
général la dernière étape c'est de leur
ordre public
mais ce qu'on entend c'est que ça fait
là faire du calmant le groupe ce qui se
passe en ce moment à ottawa
admise en des reportages journal de
montréal où le repas elle a reporté un
programme de se faire servir en français
à montréal
ça renforce donc la nécessité de
réformer cette loi les ça pourrait
peut-être même être retardé à l'an
prochain automne de l'an prochain pour
le dépôt parce que peut-être que
françois legault bout de l'enfer de
campagne électorale alors que monsieur
legault se serait bien passé de cette
autre front qui s'ouvre devant lui
madeleine mais c'est un france seraient
toutes les questions identitaires ce
sens et si le bloc québécois est là
aussi
le bloc québécois est là le bloc
québécois qui en a fait ses choux gras
cette semaine avec le parti conservateur
qui est entré dans la bataille
socialiste en a peut-être surpris
quelques-uns l'aller les effets comme
quoi la meilleure stratégie de défense
et parfois l'attaqué à les libéraux qui
ont autres s'en sont pris aux
conservateurs
en dix ans vous n'êtes même pas capable
de promettre de nommer seulement des
juges bilingues à la cour suprême comme
quoi vous n'êtes pas sérieux sur le
dossier linguistique mais les
conservateurs essaient de montrer eux
aussi aux québécois francophones qu'ils
sont sérieux et le fait que est un hôte
houle être posé des questions là-dessus
ça fait 7 vient bien plaisir je vous
dirai à la députation québécoise du
parti conservateur ils ont l'impression
qu'ils ont l'appui de leurs chefs à ce
sujet là et qu'ils peuvent peut-être
essayer de se défaire d'un certain passé
avec stephen rapp et où il y avait eu
par exemple et l'abolition du programme
de contestation judiciaire qu'il a entre
autres pour les minorités linguistiques
au pays donc un électorat qui compte
celui du québec de toute évidence on en
a eu la preuve alors rapidement les deux
à surveiller la semaine prochaine sur
vos radars madeleine devait être mon
côté notamment savoir de la semaine
prochaine quand sera la date de la mise
à jour itunes maintenant si c'est que ça
va être avant noël non c'est pas encore
ça va être des bastions
j'ai pas leurs chaussures radars mais en
fin de semaine conseil national de
québec solidaire du parti québécois des
conseils nationaux virtuel ça attire un
peu moins l'attention que ce
traditionnel où les gens se rencontrent
physiquement perce mais ça n'échappe à
l'attention de sébastien bovet seront
heureusement que n'ont qu'à nous mêmes
le même le week-end n'arrête jamais
merci beaucoup c'est vrai j'ai souffert
au salon par contre je vais suivre
seulement saine et que c'est bon vous
mettez ça sans toi tu as les revoir bon
week end
[Musique]